we live on the continent of elios
four realms surrounding a holy land at
its center
[Music]
a thousand years ago our lands endured a
vicious war with the fel dragon
we called upon heroes from other worlds
to aid us heroes known as emblems
with them the warriors of our nations
fought as one
in the end
we were victorious in defeating and
imprisoning the fel dragon
in the years since our world has been
safe
but now
i sense a resurrection
the binding weakens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're awake
oh you're really awake yeah a thousand
years that's how long i've been asleep
what are those horrible things
if i may
you are a divine dragon a member of a
royal family of dragons revered as
deities the war
the fell dragon
i feel
[Music]
leave it to me
it is rather quiet i know
but it will liven up as we gain allies
the time has come
now as one emblem
engage
[Music]
one striker decided on
[Music]
please grant me your strength
[Music]
she asked me to gather all of the rings
and bring peace back to elios
[Music]
you